all right we have a very exciting first
session started a guy first talked about
multi-perspective affairs they don't
microfilm this is the topic okay great
so thanks for inviting me to speak and
do my best to be a suitable warm-up act
for Michael's talk which will delve a
little bit deeper into recent work so I
want to sort of give a perspective I'll
talk mostly about one work from the past
but also hopefully a broader perspective
about this multi group fairness and the
talk is based on joint works with
Cynthia dork Ursula or Burt Johnson
Michael Kim oh my Rheingold and Galliano
and many thanks to my collaborators for
slides especially I'm really ruthlessly
taking advantage of Omar's slides and
this talk so if you see something you
like it's probably due to Oh Maron the
things you don't like are probably my
modifications so we know from the
cluster and the workshop yesterday that
algorithms are making and informing
really important decisions and I think
what's remarkable about this is both the
scope of the decisions that are being
made by algorithms or informed by
algorithms and the scale at which this
is happening
I'm precedented and only going to grow
and you know there are many advantages
to this but there are also concerns and
the concern for the talk today and I
guess for this whole program is
discrimination okay so what happens to
protected minorities when the decisions
are being made by algorithms and by
machine learning and it's not a new
question the study of fairness is old
and multidisciplinary spending lots of
fields the challenge of algorithmic
decision making and the scope in the
scale that I just talked about are new
and so fairness is I think attracting
explosive interest within computer
science and in particular I want to talk
about or the perspective
I want to bring as a perspective from
theoretical computer science where
there's also growing interest and I
think naiive Li may be at some point in
the past that none of us remember now
there was some hope that if the
algorithms are making the decisions they
can make more equitable decisions as we
heard yesterday and as we all know now
there's a lot of suspicion there's
mostly suspicion I think about
algorithms making decisions in fairness
and I actually want to I think the
suspicion is merited and important but I
do think that by bringing the tools of
computer science and the theoretical
computer science and cryptography to
bear on this problem maybe we can at
least have some ideas or some
perspectives on how to really make
algorithms make equitable decisions
maybe there's also some room for
optimism or certainly room for an
ambitious research agenda so thinking
about this from a theoretical
perspective what would I want as a
theoretician I would want this you know
very beautiful Holy Grail so what I
would want is to formulate an
all-encompassing general purpose
mathematical definition of fairness
that's foolproof and handles every
concern that we you know under the Sun
that's what I would want maybe well yes
there maybe not we haven't gotten there
yet and I think we haven't gotten there
for good reasons fairness is difficult
it's very context dependent it
incorporates social norms and
discrimination can be very subtle so
there's a catalogue of evils phrase this
from a work of work at all
discrimination can be very subtle it's
hard to detect hard to reason about it's
a hard problem so you know we could give
up and not work on it at all I think
that my background is in cryptography
what would a cryptographer do we can
take this very big problem you know that
very context dependent and varies a lot
in different settings we don't need to
tackle all of it at once I think we can
have a very rich and successful research
program by identifying and formalizing
particular concerns about discrimination
so you know we say that it's very
context dependent they're very different
types of discrimination there are lots
of
pterence let's start cataloging them
let's identify them let's formalize them
and come up with countermeasures that
might not be all encompassing but they
might handle serious concerns serious
particular concerns and maybe in the end
we'll actually get to this holy grail
even if we don't this is still a
valuable research program so that's
certainly the perspective for the talk
today so first of all you know from my
darling my theoretician hat if we can
have if you can start I think starting
by having a mathematical theory that we
think really tackles these problems is a
big first step and then we talk about
the track encryption had an impact early
let's argue about it over let's argue
over it during Michael's talk so I want
to talk a little bit today about so
setting up the problem in a particular I
want to talk about automated prediction
or risk scores going talk a little bit
about group fairness that's that'll be
my straw man and then going beyond it
and talking about our complexity
theoretic perspective and a particular
instantiation of a broader perspective
in this new notion of multi calibration
I'll spend most of the talk on that and
then if I have time I'm going to revisit
individual fairness in a particular
individual fairness but I'm going to be
revisit metric based fairness notions
and that's all boring tedious part and
then the second act and a double feature
will be Michael King so the setting for
both talks is that a prediction so we
want to know predict the probabilities
of events for certain individuals so we
have this individual we want to predict
maybe the probability that they'll click
on an ad or an article that's one maybe
I mean we heard yesterday about the
stakes for ads but maybe a low slow
stake or low impact prediction higher
impact predictions for medical or
insurance purposes what's the
probability that this person will have a
heart attack or another serious medical
probability that a person will repay
alone that's sort of what we want to do
we want to learn to predict problem
individual probabilities the way you
want to do it is by learning from
historical outcomes so this the model I
want to have in mind for this is that
every individual we have every
individual is represented by a set of
features and that way we want to think
about it is that every individual has an
innate individual probability
probability here is a loaded word and
I'll talk about that but every
individual has a probability of success
P star so the probability that the
individual will repay the loan the
probability that
succeed in college success probability
of having a heart attack but there are
these any probabilities or the
individual X and if the in a probability
of 0.8 what we actually get to observe
in the end we don't know what the n/a
probability is we get to observe the
outcome zero one outcome did the
individuals succeed or did they not
really random variable gets value 1 with
probability P star of X so these are the
outcomes that we see and what we want to
do is to learn to predict the actual
probabilities so we never get to see
these probabilities these in a
probability P star and still we want to
learn to predict them this we observe
for individuals outcomes why didn't in
college another individual didn't and
given a data set of such historical
outcomes we want to learn to predict P
star and the caveat when I talk about
individual probabilities you should all
you know stand up screaming and tell me
you know what's the probability over
where are these probabilities coming
from what do you mean and that's a
really good question where is a random
is coming from is this am I talking
about randomness in the universe I'm
talking about randomness that sort of I
just like are the limitations of the
data features that I have and individual
probabilities are contentious topic
statistics and economics going back
decades I don't want to open up that can
of worms it's forcing too but let's not
we won't resolve that here one thing I
do want to say is that this is happening
all over the place there are many
machine learning systems at scales of
hundreds of millions or billions of
users that are trying to predict
individual probabilities being used
every day this is our attempt we're
going to attempt to talk about fairness
in that function
yes I'm thinking about the P star every
individual has a set of a person every
individual I think of it being unique so
every individual say the set of features
is unique to the individual that
includes your identifier and P star X is
that particular individuals probability
of success and you can think of it once
it's determining success X is not a
random identifier that was uniquely
assigned to somebody at Birth X is not a
random identifier that was uniquely
assigned to somebody at Birth it's got
the information that you need
once it's unique you know you can map a
function and say there's this a function
that map's
very good question and there's no way
giving a P of X there and there's a
literature saying it's impossible to
distinguish the true it might be
impossible to think we distinguish the
true P star from some P star that's
being given but that's not the true one
and this is one of the reasons why this
is a contentious topic so I haven't
defined loss at all and I actually won't
be interested in loss because I want to
talk about fairness not about actors
some noise and the features that are
observable which is inherently there
because we can't observe every feature
it in some epsilon neighborhood there
actually that many fraction of people
who actually get so I want to take it
offline because we could talk for 45
minutes or an hour and a half or for a
three day workshop we could talk about P
star and I don't want to
so our goal is we're given a data set of
historical information you know
individuals each their features and
their outcome a zero one outcome and
what we want to do is learn a predictor
P the probability that individuals will
repay their loan to decide whether to
give them a loan or not
that's sort of the framework we're in
and the thing I want to talk about so I
don't want to talk about accuracy the
thing I'm really concerned with right
now is fairness once we have these
predictors what does it mean for a
predictor to be fair what are the
concerns we might have and when we're
doing machine learning on this kind of
historical data
there's biases everywhere I like this
quote that machine learning is money
laundering for bias take your bias you
know bake it into a predictor and say
this is the predictor and you've
laundered away your bias supposedly but
it's still there so there's biases
biases through the machine learning
pipeline there's bias in the data there
might be bias in the historical data
what I want to talk about today is that
there might be further bias even if the
data itself the historical outcome data
is unbiased which it isn't
there might be further biased biases
introduced in the data analysis and the
algorithm it's doing the machine
learning itself this can be either
malicious or inadvertent so for example
if we have some protected minority or
protected group eff that on average are
more likely to default in the general
population
the machine learning may just completely
give up on s make the problem much worse
because the machine learning is
constrained right we want to output some
predictor that has a constrained
complexity and maybe the machine
learning algorithm will just decide to
give up on s entirely including the
qualified members so making the problem
much worse so biases then we could talk
about many other sources of bias through
the machine learning okay this is going
to be an important one for the part of
it so how do we reason about the
fairness of a predictor so one way which
I'm going to argue is naive is this idea
of group notions of fairness where the
the formalization or what we would want
is to say that in aggregate we we have a
protected group s and we want the
predictor in aggregate to behave
similarly on the protected group to the
general population in aggregate here is
very important
similarly could mean different things so
there are different notions statistical
parity says that the outcomes may be the
average prediction on s mu is the same
or for every possible outcome it's
equally likely on s and in the general
population and we can talk about similar
false positive or false negative rates
we could talk about calibration which is
a notion of accuracy that I'll talk
about more so various interpretations of
what it means to behave similarly and
each of them would give us a group you
know a group sort of aggregate notion of
fairness so certainly I think this can
sometimes it can it can make sense to
check whether statistical parity or
balance or calibration hold it might be
a red flag for your particular setting
if statistical parity doesn't hold but
the fact that statistical parity holds
only gives you a very weak guarantee are
you so taking as fairness definitions
these are very weak and easy to abuse
moreover they're at odds with each other
by told the Coba and by Kleinberg and
and another question is which group s
are we trying to protect what do we I
mean who are the protected group and I
want to say this is a critical question
so even if I want to protect even what I
want to do is protect a group notion and
as long as I'm and I know the group I
you know I know a particular minority
that or a particular protected group
that I want to ensure fairness for I
might not be protecting important
subgroups so the beautiful example from
the work of Dwarka Dahl is the example
of a steak house that's trying to
advertise trying to avoid advert to
avoid having customers from the
group s and you know maybe they want
maybe you know for legal purposes or
just Republic Relations they want to
show that they advertise at the same
rate to the general population and to
members of s so you know they want to
satisfy statistical parity and they can
do this by advertising to vegetarians in
s and to meat-eaters in the general
population to meat-eaters outside of us
so statistical parity is satisfied maybe
they advertise to one percent in both
groups but clearly they're advertising
to the people that are never going to
show up in to say cups so statistical
parity would allow this but like
equalized odds for all of them right I
agree but this one in particular I think
this one in pic Euler would be
problematic if you tell me that your
fairness notion is equalized odds I'll
come up with a different example you're
assuming here that you can't actually
measure who shows up at the restaurant
as soon as you do that show I agree
but what I want to say is that for any
notion that you come up with I know I'll
take it offline but we'll we can play
this game during the break and maybe
I'll need help from the audience but for
any proposed move notion or any maybe
you can propose one a new one and you
know I'll be forced to take it back but
my statement is that for any group
notion that you try to throw at me or at
us as an audience will be able to come
up with an example that is latent ly
unfair even though it's satisfied that
that's been my experience
he's that I'm trying to push you on is
I'd like to understand more about what
the model is that you're using and so
then there's sort of an underlying model
that I want to try to understand more
that you see missing so you know my
claim is that here the concern here
you're right that my concern that's not
being handled is who is and isn't
showing up at the Statehouse and a nice
we're saying well let's measure that and
then let's sort of let's legislate that
the Statehouse has to have equal
representation for all groups I think
that's a fine suggestion we could talk
about more subtle concerns than sort of
you know for example for hiring and
again you might but there's this issue
of like a self-fulfilling prophecy that
companies interview token candidates
from protected groups but they select
the ones that aren't going to pass the
interview and so they say oh we actually
you know looking at measuring who shows
up for the interview the appropriate
people are showing up for the interview
they're just not qualified and so they
weren't hired and then you could say
well let's measure who actually gets
hired a measure who actually got tired
and you know this could be a game that
we could play til infinity I agree with
you that if what we want to guarantee is
that the thing we're measuring is equal
across groups then we can guarantee the
moment you know we go beyond that if we
want to guarantee something more than
that then we can come up with more
subtle like you know if you're hiring
them but you're not promoting them maybe
you're hiring them into certain roles
and aunt into others so is it
complicated very quickly and also maybe
you're hiring let's talk about a
protected group and then you know maybe
we'll get to that in a moment maybe
you're hiring appropriately within the
protected group but you're not hiring
within a subgroup say a gender subgroup
and we worry about that as well
here claim that any notion can have some
counter example I guess the things you
listed on all feel like notions of being
able to distinguish the output could you
just generalize that and say any
computationally founded distinguisher
kinda like in cryptography right you
have all these different tests you know
I'm not sure but I'm going to suggest
taking it offline okay so the point in
this take outside and the point I want
to make you know maybe there's
intersection of s with some other
protected attribute like gender that we
want to protect so for fairness it's
really important to identify the
relevant subgroups
okay so relevant subgroup here was the
carnivores yes that wasn't you know
that's uh that can get difficult tasks
actually thinking through who the
relevant subgroups are can be very
challenging similarly we want to make
sure that the qualified loan applicants
whatever that means
are getting similar treatment so
figuring out who the relevant subgroup
is is a difficult task in our
perspective which was also taken in
Karen's Neil Roth and Wu is to protect
every set that can be identified and
maybe this is going a little bit well
every set that can be identified from
the data within given computational
limitations within a given complexity
class for example maybe every group that
can be identified say with polynomial
size circuits that would be a very
strong respective sorry is that we don't
necessarily know who the relevant
subgroups are that can be a difficult
task and so just try to protect all of
them or at least all the all of them is
difficult
ask a question I'll tell you why but
certainly try to protect everyone that
can be identified by a reasonably
complex so what I mean is that the
protection we want you know maybe it's
it's some sort of statistical parity
maybe it's some level of some notion of
accuracy like calibration or gets to
which I'll get to in a moment that
should hold that property should hold
for every group that I can identify
efficiently ok so it doesn't necessarily
mean that I have to accept all the
people in every group that I can
identify but the fairness notion that
I'm after should hold for every group
that's identified in the intuition is
your perfect prediction you do have to
you do have to be slightly improper
so the thing I want to do now for most
of the talk is talk about a particular
instantiation of this perspective for
this notion of calibration where then
what we'll want to guarantee is
calibration which is a notion of
accuracy that I'll get to in a minute
for every subset in a rich family seat
so for every subset and think about this
family seat as some sort of
computational class okay so maybe it's
every subset that can be identified
identified I mean there's sort of a
circuit in the class or a computational
object in the class that can decide
whether X is in the subset or not
whether an individual X within the
subset or not so every subset that can
be identified say by circuits of a
certain size by conjunctions whatever
computational class you want to consider
we'll try to do is guarantee calibration
or a different notion for every subset
in that class simultaneously and notice
here that I'm not talking about one
group or two groups or five groups this
could be an exponential number of groups
will be an exponential number so in
particular if the carnivores can be
identified within the family see we can
now guarantee statistical parity or in
this case we'll talk about raishin for
them if the qualified loan applicants
can be identified by four-way
conjunctions they will guarantee
calibration that's really the intuition
is we want to make sure that the
qualified candidates are not being
passed over or are not being ignored or
not being ignored within within any
protected
so what's this notion of calibration or
what's the notion I want so before doing
that a nice warm up notion is multi what
we call multi accuracy where what we
would want is that in aggregate for
every group in C so for every one of
these exponential number of groups the
expectation the aggregate expectation of
the predictor we output is about equal
to the aggregate expectation the correct
P star that's one notion of accuracy
that we could want to guarantee for all
the groups
notice that the fact that the
expectation is correct in aggregate
doesn't say anything that's going back
to your question it doesn't say that for
individuals we have actors but in
aggregate over the group for every
single group in my class I want to have
an accurate expectations calibration
just takes us one step further and
actually says that for every group if I
look at the people within that group who
got prediction V V is a value between
zero and one really about V of them
should have output one or really the
expectation the true expectation of P
star for those people should be about V
so for all the people who got prediction
V within the group about V of them a V
fraction of them should get label one
that's what we calibration and this is
really going back to the concerns I
talked about before this is a notion of
fairness that's really rooted in
accuracy we're trying to get a certain
notion of accuracy and of course if the
data is biased that bias might be
perpetuated it's not going to protect us
still I think that you can predict can
protect us from further evils so from
the algorithm the machine learning
itself and also both in this talk and in
Michaels talk we'll we'll see how once
we have this notion even if the data
were biased we can start talking about
corrective discrimination what we talked
about doing the biases we need to have
something that's really accurate for all
the groups it also be a stepping stone
towards that example you can think about
which is nice I think this is ageism in
health care so we have diseases that are
under diagnosed in elderly patients or
other populations because they can be
masked as
age-related symptoms so for training
machine learning if we're using machine
learning and its complexity is
constrained it might choose to optimize
on younger patients it's going to get
more bang for its buck by really
understanding the young patient
population really well and it might
under serve or misdiagnosed the elderly
patients now we hear we don't want
statistical purity we certainly don't
want to distil apparentiy we don't want
it over correct because really often
maybe it is age related symptoms but not
an underlying disease and we don't want
to always you know to always say always
conduct tests and treatment that might
be harmful so really what we want or
what we want is the first step would be
something like calibration or a notion
of accuracy saying that we can't just
ignore the elderly population we also
want today of knows we sit within the
elderly population
so related works I think the most
related one is this works I talked about
if hearings and all who take a similar
perspective they focus on notions like
to statistical parity imbalance whereas
we focus on calibration been a few works
now taking this perspective or building
on this perspective one that I want to
point out is this work the accuracy by
Iranian Zoo and they do they work with
multi accuracy so not multi calibration
but the weaker notion or decide be more
relaxed notion and actually do some
experiments they have encouraging
experimental result using a new
algorithm to guarantee is multi accuracy
and they also show how to use that
algorithm to correct bias data using
very few good samples so maybe we have a
large data set of biased examples but we
have a few unbiased examples and we can
use those few to correct to both learn
from the larger bias data set but also
correct another place where even though
we're talking about accuracy based
notions it actually helped even when
your data is lies so the flavor of
results we have with multi calibration
first you might ask you know is it even
possible maybe this is too strong a
definition or it can only rarely be
achieved and we show actually that there
always exists a multi calibrated
predictor and in fact it's not much it's
not some monstrous complicated beast
it's about as efficient a little bit
less efficient than just membership
checking for tests for sets within the
class this isn't science fiction
actually small and efficient multi
calibrated predictors do exist once we
specify our class one question is can we
find them so we have an algorithm that
learns from just label data sets so it
learns from outcomes its complexity is
linear in the size of the class and the
number of sets were protecting of course
I said that can be exponential and so
linear in the size of C might not be
good enough for us we're talking about
ten way conjunctions maybe it's feasible
if we're talking about all circuits of
size s then probably it's not feasible
and we showed that this is inherent
there's a tight relationship between
multi calibration and a type of weak
agnostic learning this is bad news
if you think that weak agnostic if you
think that agnostic we're keeping in
mind that we know that agnostic learning
is often hard in the worst case but you
can maybe can be good knows good news
because we know that in practice all the
time for the running time it's the size
that gives us the lower bound for the
sample complexity I believe so the upper
bound really what the algorithm is doing
is enumerated over the class there's no
notion of proper or improper here we're
not assuming anything about P starts so
we don't know anything about it yeah
it's going back to the point that I'm
not trying to guarantee accurate you
know the actual error l1 or l2 error
and the last thing I want to say is that
we can also impose this multi
calibration through post-processing
it'll only improve your error so okay so
I'm gonna be ambitious and I want to
actually show you this algorithm and
it's not so ambitious because I can fit
the algorithm on a single slide so
before showing you the algorithm just
see we understand exactly what our task
is so we're given a sample of training
data size and Y is and we know the class
C that we want to protect the goal is to
learn a predictor that's multi
calibrated on see there's this alpha
slackness parameter multi calibration
remote the accuracy a these expectations
I said were about equal the expectation
of P star and of the predictor P were
about equal they're equal up to an alpha
factor the smaller alpha is the better
the guarantee but the more complicated
the more data we'll need and the more
complicated the issue is we don't want
to just be multi calibrated or multi
accurate on the training sample we want
to generalize outside it whatever
distribution these x i's are coming
forth from we want to generalize to that
distribution we're not assuming anything
about P star since we're not in any sort
of realizable setting the naive thing
we'll just look at all the intersections
of all the groups naively we're not
gonna get very far actually what we show
is that you can learn this predictor the
overhead is polynomial in one over alpha
so this slackness guarantee and the
running time we said is linear in the
number of sets being protected in
polynomial in one over L so how does
this algorithm actually work that's the
algorithm in a box
the way we start is first we know
nothing so we're just going to
initialize our predictor to say 1/2 for
everyone and then the algorithm just
repeatedly looks for a set where
calibration is violated so you know if
this predictor is already good great
we're done probably it won't be so we're
going to enumerate over all the sets in
the class C and over all the possible
predictions and we're going to try to
find a category within a set a set T
that's supposed to be protected and a
prediction v we're calibration is
violated there's a dispute is a ssin
issues here that I'm brushing aside
we're looking for a separate calibration
is violated once we find this set all
we're going to do is correct our
predictors correct the expectation of
our predictor on that set so right now
the predictor is saying V for everyone
in the set the predictor calibration is
violated so P star is not saying V for
that something far away from V so we
just want to correct and we're going to
move everyone's predictions within the
set we're going to move them in the
direction of B in the direction of the
true values very good question so the
question is okay so that's an algorithm
but immediately your brush this under
the rug but you won't let me so of
course I don't know P star we don't know
it and you know I had this whole long
spiel about the fact that we want to
learn from outcomes not from P star but
we can estimate this expectation very
well this is an expectation of P star so
we can estimate it very well from label
data and wait a slide if you still have
a question about that
so is it possible to replace an
enumeration step-over
C by some optimization Oracle 4c yes so
we do in fact have such a reduction
saying that if you have some sort of an
agnostic learning Oracle for C then you
can actually do this step efficiently
that's why it's sort of that's one
direction of the equivalence for this
and that out give is that you're going
you were not able to leave you yes okay
and as a heuristic maybe you could just
run your favorite machine learning
algorithm and see what happens here
maybe it'll maybe it'll find you such a
say it's Oracle so you're you're just
not worrying about like finite sample
variability here basically right we do
so what do you make P starters gonna
take the fraction of that sub particular
so I have this alpha slackness that I'm
going for and I need my sample to be
large enough so at least it sort of 1
over alpha squared to know that the
empirical expectation within my sample
is very close to the true wonderful so
it's required if you start from
everything being without word no that's
a great question and when I talked
before about running this about imposing
multi calibration as post-processing
you could start with whatever you want
kind of your favorite predictor and you
could run the algorithm starting with
that they put so converge and have you
seen
accuracy way to different final accuracy
rates started inaccurate with your very
simple I'm sure it will lead to I'm sure
it will these do
yeah so if you calibrate them every
single Tommy then your cartridge door
open right
so why depend on the size of see it is
just because secretly exponential in the
number of single just welcome for single
tones and you're done so if I could work
on the singletons then I would but that
requires a that actually hires a doubly
exponential family so it won't work so
there are two problems with Singleton's
first I can't estimate this unless the
group has large fractional mess within
the distribution so my algorithm will
fail but also sort of conceptually if
you want to and again I want to really
stress that this all works we don't need
to reason about the kind of accuracy you
need to achieve so we can work in a
totally agnostic setting it's still
guaranteed this notion of fairness and
that's important so we really wanted to
we want to handle the situation where we
can't avoid making errors we can't
really recover the correct a star and
still we want a reason about fairness we
can
do you know if he really needs the
groups to like bandage complexity as
opposed to just the groups not being too
small I think it in the setting that he
thought about for positive rates like we
eventually figured out that like
actually we didn't need founded see the
mentioned for the group's we just needed
them to not be too small and I wonder if
the same is true didn't we do because
you're always going to have you know if
your algorithm in the end the predictor
is not perfect it makes errors then you
could always define the group on which
it's making errors in one way or another
you're going to be very bad so I think
it's I think it's important now are you
worried about instead of groups
oh did you repeat your question
yes if so I mean what we figured out in
our setting where we're thinking about
false positive rates is you do need
bounded VC dimension for the class of
functions so if you're learning over but
for the class of groups you want to
protect to turned out I think you only
need you know none of them are small
please you guys include circuits for
determining whether somebody is in a
group as part of the classifier yeah so
I don't know what it's all X we're not
assuming anything about I think there
are two classes there's the class that
you're sort of if you want to assume P
star is coming from some class and then
there's the class of groups we're
talking about and we're not assuming
that these stars coming from any class
we're not bounding it at all and when
you do that then you do have to bound
the complexity loops I think we were
assuming that P star was coming from
some class
okay the one subtlety that I'm glossing
over here is you know I told you that
well these are you know expectations of
large groups floret hopefully large
enough groups so we can just estimate
them expectation estimate them from our
label data and we all nod it along but
actually this is subtle because the
group that we're looking at is
adaptively chosen okay so we're looking
at the data we're determining our
predictor in previous rounds and that
defines for us the group and now we're
trying to measure the expectation of
that group so that's circular and that
can be that's the question of adaptive
sort of adaptively estimating
expectations or adaptive data analysis
and if you don't do anything if you just
sort of look at this and run it there's
no guarantee that for an adaptively
chosen group T sub V the people who the
people within - you got prediction V
there's no guarantee that the empirical
expectation and the true expectation are
close so naively you can just use a
fresh sample for each actually should
have said so we've run these iterations
until there are no such groups when
there are no such groups and by
definition we're calibrated and we just
returned the predictor of the result so
lately in each iteration of these
algorithm you could use an fresh sample
you can use a smaller sample using
differential privacy and the connection
between different
okay is there an assumption here that
when you adapt for one group that you
aren't growing up the calibration for
other groups it might be so you might be
you might be and the question is why
does this converge and I lost it over
but there's a potential analysis that
basically shows that you know we're
starting there's the real p star we have
no idea what it is we're starting with
this P that's totally naive and giving
everyone a half every time we update
we're getting closer
so the potential argument that actually
shows that the distance between P and P
star is shrinking every time you update
so it might be that you're violating
calibration on some other group but your
distance from the star is actually
shrinking every time so this can't
happen forever polynomial number of
updates you will it seems like it would
still be it is it does work this will be
you might have a worse bound but it will
still converge it just depends on the
distance you start with right so every
time sort of shrinking your distance by
some factor of alpha that depends on
alpha global you're singers globally you
keep moving in the right direction
yes okay so I just want to say in am uh
since I'm running out of time I want to
say a word about so this was this
perspective about talk about protecting
all groups that can be identified within
a certain class and the particular
instantiation that I talked about was
multi calibration and accuracy
protections still this leaves us with a
desire there was the holy grail that I
had earlier this beautiful chalice to
have an all-encompassing or very
flexible definition that can handle many
concerns we have such a definition so I
want to end with that I was saying and
kind of with what this multi group
perspective actually tells us about
individual individual fairness says
similar individuals should be treated
similarly where similarity between
individuals is measured by a similarity
metric or Delta similar to each other
then they should get similar output
distributions may be similar
distributions of the what the predictor
assigns to them so they're very close in
the metric these distributions should be
very close and if they're far then
there's no constraints and the beauty of
this of this definition is that you have
this metric which can serve as a vehicle
for all of your sort of context and all
of the societal concerns and all the
subtlety that's inherent
so this can be very task-specific this
metric and it really gives you a robust
and flexible notion of parents the
question is where does this metric come
from so and that's a good question and
we have such metrics it's so first of
all once you specify it it's open to
debate assignment we have some examples
of this in the real world but there are
challenges with metric fairness so one
challenge is generalization from a
training set and the other is the
assumption that the entire metric is
maybe realistically we can only have a
limited sample and we can use the multi
group perspective that I talked about to
relaxed individual fairness a little bit
in order to get both generalization and
the ability to learn when we only have a
limited sample and this requires a shout
out to Christina's amazing work so there
are related work they didn't talk about
ours but who works about lonely learning
with an unknown fairness metric and
Cristina's work that was just mentioned
on learning from very limited
information about this and just
summarize so as we said discrimination
can be subtle it's hard to pin down it's
hard to formalize mathematically the
goal is to come up with families of
definitions either parametrize
definitions like the individual fairness
and the metric based the other metric
based definitions or definitions that
are tailored to particular fairness
concerns like multi calibration and we
have this multi group perspective which
i think is leading us towards an
interesting path for doing
I talked about multi calibration and
coming right up
Michael we'll talk about evidence-based
rain just take the questions offline